valérie fait pipi mère maman merci
bonjour à derry ça va oui j'ai un petit
peu envie d'en savoir un peu plus sur
valérie lemercier j'ai vu votre
spectacle
on peut commencer pas de problème non
plus j'ai tout mon temps
j'aime bien votre émission alors d'où
venez vous d'abord c'est quoi la famille
l'entourage la renardière tiens c'est
quoi quand tu connais pas la renardière
c'est génial ça fait les centaines
d'années qu'on est là bas on est ravi
l'été on fait des grandes tablées on
aime en der en plus on retrouve tout le
temps les têtes que dans les collèges
maman qu'on n'a pas vu depuis des années
quand les beatles hommes je voulais
savoir avec ce spectacle est difficile
d'avoir un moment pour soi pour
s'occuper de sa maison
non je commence mon linge au dimanche
matin comme ça se fait bien g20 journée
oui je fais mais les noir jaune à mal
matin mais après manger je fais mes
machines
en général j'en fais une à 40 puis doit
81 disent oui oh oui oh oui moi tout ce
qui est que dans tu fais bouillir
vous vous intéressez je pense à ce qui
se passe un petit peu autour de vous non
est ce que vous seriez prête à vous
engager personnellement service d'une
cause humanitaire les enfants dans le
monde et ce terrain bah oui parce que tu
sais quand je serai grand débat je
m'occuperai de tous ses enfants parce
que tu sais les petits noirs on croit qu
ils sont gros parce qu'ils ont un grand
vente mais c'est parce que je kiffe
tellement ils sont maigres
bah oui parce que comme ils ont très
faim et balsa val de l'eyre contraire
ils font comme très peace un grand oui
très mignonne avez vous envie parfois de
crier de mettre les poings sur la table
de faire valser ce qui vous entoure les
gens les choses
attendez là non mais vous pouvez
continuer à poser des questions mais
c'est possible de parler un peu moins
fort je suis vraiment crevé en plus je
n'aime pas c'est impartial d'urbanisme
pas de problème je peux mais je m'en
fous complètement
et alors là valérie qui sommeille en
vous l'autre scène qu'on ne voit pas
comment est elle en émotions le royal et
pendrel a baissé un peu mais s'est calmé
un appel parce que moi alors j'ai un
petit peu envie de vous poser la
question finalement est ce que est ce
que vous êtes angoissé
parce que c'est vrai on dit parfois que
les comiques dans la vie ne sont pas
toujours très gai très drôle c'est vrai
ça c'est pau pour bien fossiles non pour
les comme c'est indirect de télévision
avant je t'ai peau bien je viens dit sur
l'autre vaut mieux jeudi poc sur un dû
mais j'ai comme l'impression d'être au
bout du tunnel
volot oui je comprends bien et qu'est ce
qui vous fait le plus rire chez les gens
leur humour et quels sont vos rapports
avec les autres comiques les femmes
comique mieux eux mais elles ont un
grand qui les prennent toute la place de
seconde à 30,15 l'audi existe et vos
rapports avec le théâtre en général d'un
violent raiponce chien est normal on 10
10 10 10 on n'est pas chez les grecs
niort vient et puis je vais terminer en
vous demandant tout simplement votre mot
préféré sarabande
dites moi votre première télé c'était
l'académie des neuf de jean pierre
foucault riz un don vous y êtes allé
avec une amie qui travaillait sur le
plateau il n'y avait pas de pas de
candidat vous appris comme candidat je
ne voulais pas aller à la télé et on m'a
dit à personne est ce que tu veux y
aller et hangzhou mimétique est mari
parce qu'elle est pas d'étiquette la
musique
jour commencé mon par des malentendus
renom s'est toujours trompé un genre se
tromper de nontron et vous avez gagné
une caméra quand même oui mieux qu'une
caméra une machine à coudre des tas de
choses un sac à pain un sac à pain un
coffret de 10 de maria callas le coffret
du sénégal à l'afp ahmad al-rubaye voilà
madame ricky madame ont épié dites moi
alors vous avez quand même un jugement
très négatif s'est pas mariée à bon
s'ils voulaient vraiment le feuilleton
oui bah oui attendait pas revu depuis
l'émission de samedi 15e veronica vous
entendez par vu marie laforêt il n'y a
rien entre eux pour le moment
bon alors non vous vous avez un jugement
quand même négatif sur la télé vous dit
par exemple que souvent on dit qu'est ce
t'as fait hier soir tu as fait quelque
chose hier soir non j'ai regardé la télé
oui on me demandait la différence entre
le cinéma et la télévision je disais
quand on dit qu'est ce que tu as fait
cet après midi je suis allé au cinéma
qu'est ce que tu as fait ce après midi
rien j'ai regardé la rien j'ai regardé
la télé voilà c'est vrai je vois les
gens disent ça en fait sauf quand il
parle de tout le monde en parle mais
sinon oui ça peut vous démission et
s'est pas faire quelque chose c'est à
tendance dit à la télé on vous pose
jamais les bonnes questions balizy
posez-moi les bonnes questions
bah oui c'est pour ça que je vous dis ça
je sais plus et puis signé dix ans c'est
possible
vous dites par exemple quand j'ai trop
parlé à la télé alors j'espère vous
allez parler soir parce que sinon ça va
être terrible dit quand j'ai trop parlé
à la télé je voudrais faire un petit
trou dans la terre et disparaître dedans
il est vrai parfois quand je parle trop
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment je suis tout
le temps en interview elle
j'ai envie de me taire oui bon ça assez
salutaire bon mais ses terres
taisez-vous 10 secondes
je peux
mais vous dites quand on se tait sale av
oui hein vous est propre place et
l'attrition elle a pris son bain oui bah
vous disiez je moi j'aime bien faire une
télé avec des invités qui viendrait pas
uniquement pour vendre quelque chose ou
est ce que les invités viennent quand
ils ont rien à vendre
vous avez télé sans avoir mais
j'aimerais faire une émission de voir
dieudonné qui lui est à maintenant c'est
aux lithiques d'abord être est
désintéressé puis ensuite à toute une
politique en politique comme comme
humaniste un humaniste un utopiste
d'utopistes voilà aussi un petit peu
éclairé le public le peuple français qui
les regardent qui me regardent qui
regardent votre mission hybride et qui
est certainement intéressés par ce que
je veux dire tout à l'heure chapeau bas
l'or mais là j'espère vous n'êtes pas là
couvrant dossier vous avez par celui-ci
et bien oui oui moi je tiens à vous non
je suis présenté notre avis parce que
voilà dans le film die des brunes garde
donc dans le film ça vous fait un
personnage formidable
merci et alors il est à peu près le
contraire du de son rôle parce qu'il a à
l'accent du nord il vient du nord
il n'est pas danseur donc il a pris des
cours de danse il aa pris l'accent du
sud est devenu danseur à l'accent du sud
alors qu'il est comédien à l'accent du
nord
c'est pour ça que je suis venu là ce
soir pour bien dire j'étais pas de
montpellier vous étonne montpellier non
non ils tous vous faites bien l'accent à
oui merci
faites-le pour voir la puce ça m'a plu
et ça pendant tout le film c'est génial
voilà ce film ce film
s'appelle le derrière donc à moi c'est
assez joli je trouve assez déçu et c'est
enfantin c'est un mot qu'on n'emploie
plus beaucoup non non non mais ça veut
dire beaucoup de choses et le derrière
premier et deuxième degrés tout ce qu'on
faisait là plus on peut dire que c'est
justement encore sa place moi je préfère
fait les fesses avec we hope autant il
peut penser que ça va il s'appelait
maman j'ai sucé papa non ce n'est pas
vrai nom sendak j'avais dit un jour un
studio magazine
ça s'est fait dans des cailloux briques
oui en vain de nous c'est pas bon ça
jamais été écrit sur le sur la nage au
début sinon ça fait il s'appelait
friterie ça c'est vrai chris était sur
le tournage pour pouvoir louer des dvd
audi où les maîtres mots qu'à lyon on a
on a mis un titre ne pourra pas avoir
toujours à s'expliquer devant claude
rich et croyez vraiment que ça allait
s'appeler frifri écrit-il la flûte le
fils dans les rues quand sa fille a dit
papa tu joues dans un film qui s'appelle
le derrière ils étaient moins content
quand même
oui mais quand il a vu le film il était
très content maintenant absolument bon
là c'est nous qu'on a souvent viré
télévision qui parce qu'on avait chez
drucker par exemple dimanche dernier où
elle va pisser aux beaux arts le nom de
la commune
vous avez appris à marcher comme ça
comment ça s'est passé il a passé
charles dans la démarche
ça c'est que moi si on me demandait
vraiment de faire pipi comme un garçon
je sais le faire
oui je le faisais dans mon premier
spectacle mais là je me suis dit voilà
une fille qui ne sait pas d'ailleurs
elle n'a jamais quasiment vide homme de
sa vie la seule chose qu'elle connaisse
de la sexualité c'est les saillies des
chevaux et donc je sais je me suis mise
à la place d'une fille qui a jamais vu
deux hommes de sa vie et qui pensent
faire pipi comme un garçon alors
j'imagine très mal moi même un garçon en
train de marquer les jambes comme ça moi
j'ai appris ça n'existe pas ap à rocco
siffredi qui peut pas faire autrement
oui mais les autres mais lui il serait
très loin
mais savait depuis les visiteurs vous
avez pris un peu conscience on peut dire
de votre corps dont vous assumez mieux
non physiquement ben c'est à dire que
quand j'ai commencé à jouer j'étais très
jeune et genre et je faisais sûrement
pas jeunes et voilà je me remets un peu
je retourne dans mon âge oui dans le
film donc on vous voit de dos on voit on
voit vos fesses un vote derrière donc
est devant vous aviez quoi alors eh bien
je m'étais coller un petit post-it parme
pour nous préserver une certaine j'ai
postulé
comment il est plus facile jaune il
était ce qu'il était grand mais pas
parce que toi tous les post it tu
dévoiles jours est ce qu'il était les
postiers sont noirs tous les post it
sont je sais qu'il faut dépasser
ah ouais non alors il n'était pas un
cachet j'étais un gros post it war est
égaré comme ça mais j'avais bien en
triant c'est vrai que gildas la première
fois que il vous a interdit à la télé
vous avez dit que vous avez un physique
difficile
oui mais j'avais sera nuageux trop
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire il s'y
connaît
mais quand on vous dit les choses comme
ça vous n'avez pas dire non ouais bon
alors dernière question enfin dernière
sur le sujet vous dit vous dites dans
vous dites toujours dans la promo
frédéric elle est comme ça parce que
finalement elle mélange un peu tout les
tous les homos ils croient que tous les
homos sont pareils elle confond les feux
lasser les top classe
vous dites que c'est sa vision des homos
qu'elle se fait une fausse idée des
aumières sur la place des femmes auprès
des homos est ce que tout ça c'est pas
des alibis parce qu'il n'est pas
politiquement correct de dire que vous
avez fait un film qui caricaturent les
homos mais je pense que ça qu'un car je
pense que sa caricature pas du tout je
pense qu on envoie pour une fois de
toutes sortes c'est à dire qu'il ya
plein de gens qui s'imaginent que tous
les autres sont comme ça et je pense que
il ya des ministres qui a débouché il ya
des maquilleurs il y avait donc moi je
pense que c'est pas une caricature
puisqu'il y en a il y en a 10
oui mais enfin j'ai l'impression en vous
entendant lisant vos interviews que vous
n'arrivez pas à dire ce que vous êtes
peut-être vous avez peur c'est pas très
politiquement correct de dire oui j'ai
fait un film pour me [ __ ] de la gueule
des homos après tout n'est ce pas oui
alors filmé le jeu pas si c'est voilà
vous connaissez le dernier meilleur sur
le derrière de valérie lemercier gelé
connu avant que ce soit un film
voyez j'ai beaucoup aimé et j'adore
valérie lemercier vous avez déclaré je
préfère jouer 500 fois un spectacle que
d'aller une fois à la télé on vous pose
jamais les bonnes questions être
animatrice jamais ça sera un cauchemar
je préfère me pendre par exemple vous
dites aussi c'est assez finement noter
vous dit comment par exemple tu as fait
quelque chose hier soir non j'ai regardé
la tv je suis allé au cinéma les petits
trucs chez moi enfin si on invitait plus
les gens qu'on rien à dire il y aura pas
de télé éteignez votre tv dijon et
prenait un bon lieu pour dire que
philippe gildas a pas été sympa avec
vous parce que votre première télé il a
dit que vous aviez un physique difficile
oui c'est pas faux ce que non ben je
veux dire dépend non je trouve très bien
là non là vous êtes là je pense que je
me donne du mal mais là c'est bien lui
c'est un prix de diane
non mais c'est pas grave il y avait bien
eu pourtant vous êtes j'étais un peu
comme ça un peu en colère après la télé
pourtant il ya eu un moment de
télévision avec vous qui est inoubliable
donc on va faire comme chez arthur
magnéto serge la nouvelle est que lui
fans
j'appelle
une belle grande jeune fille vient
oh c'est philippe bouvard qu'il avait
utilisé à avancer pour ça c'est mieux là
comme ça ma petite fille ferme qui peut
grand mais ça fait rien comment tu
t'appelles audeline eaux de tallinn
fillon mais cédric dents longues et à
l'école ils m'appellent [ __ ] les
enfants sont cruels
comment taper un e ou habitue trou du
cul mon papa il a dit pas les dire et
pourquoi il ya des villes un monsieur
qui va lui reprendre la voiture neuve
tu sais comment on les appelle ses
villas monsieur non on les appelle des
huissiers nar 18 kg et ezequiel prendre
les meubles que papa aniche et ont tendu
où il est on pas peur là bas montre le
mois à je le vois c'est le gros monsieur
avec la caméra
bonjour monsieur comment s'appelle-t-il
ton papa papa
les enfants sont merveilleux et la dame
à côté c'est ta maman non c'est monique
elle dort avec nous dans la somme de
papa et elle mais pas tellement une
pyjama et les gentils monuc
oui mais des fois elle me met tout nu
dans un placard
j'aime pas tellement tellement c'est
merveilleux qu'est ce qu'il fait dans la
vie ton papa il nettoie le cas des morts
à l'hôpital tessier non non ne riez pas
il n'ya pas de sot métier même s'il ya
des métiers avec un saut dans lequel on
met la home home aaa
il aime bien son travail ton papa bah
oui mais aussi aux deux camps qui
rentrent de l'école sans mourir monique
elle aime pas trop alors elle me dit
qu'est ce que tu es jolie aude lune
c'est monique qui m'a coupé les cheveux
très bien vendu très bien tu as une très
très jolie robe qui est ce qu'il te la
donner on n'a pas daigné ont lâché
elle fait la cuisine me dis qu'est ce
qu'elle te fais à manger de lui
[Rires]
[Musique]
est ce que tu sais adeline qu'est ce que
tu voudras faire quand tu seras plus
grand vide et les truies vider les trucs
c'est pas banal comme ça je pourrais en
manger plein avec deux frites nom avec
de l'huile
alors les enfants sont formidables
une école du fan vous le savez consacré
au chanteur mort
est ce que tu aimes bien les chanteurs
morts oui qui tu aimes comme chanteur
moeurs hervé wiart
il est pas mort hervé vilard il est mort
les enfants sont formidables
excusez-nous hervé nom hervé vilard
n'est pas mort ma petite fille
alors qu'est ce que tu vas de chanter
capri c'est fini
non hervé vilard n'est pas mort tu va
nous chanter comme on avait dit bobby
nom de dalida qui elle est morte tu as
vu son hommage à jean pierre foucault
ça veut dire qu'elle est morte est ce
que tu as vu un hommage à hervé vilard
chez jean pierre foucault non non ça
veut dire qu'il est toujours vivant
alors pineau vrai tu es très tôt de
lille bouvines on line et de l'hymne
hervé vilard n'est pas mort tu devais
chantait dalida mauvais dans la bouche
merci dans l'émission de les nuls
[Applaudissements]
là derrière donc c'est votre film qui
sort en cassette et qui sort aussi en
dvd
oui pour les riches je le dis voilà donc
ça sort en dvd donc vous avez toujours
refusé que vos spectacles sortant
cassette vidéo wii sont pas filmés sont
jamais voté ce spectacle génial que avec
quand vous disiez j'ai des cousins qu'on
débite énorme
c'est intelligent ça jamais psp canon et
les j'en ai fait un autre que j'ai joué
six mois au théâtre de paris
mais non plus non plus je le verrai
jeunes mais pour le coup voilà vous
allez reprendre je bats j'ai une grande
nouvelle à vous annoncer que je serai
sur la scène des folies bergère à partir
du 26 septembre à ce génial c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande donc je vous demande de vous
arrêter
bien alors donc le dernier m2 vaut
arrêter toi aussi arrête toi enfin quand
même qu'est ce qu'il a à z et là il est
même pas maire de paris edwards est noir
alors un film de vous avec vous claude
rich et dieudonné
oui le derrière alors je fais je vous
raconte l'histoire vous le faites non à
dialyse ici je suis de le faire alors
c'est à la mort de sa mère une jeune
femme se met à rechercher son père elle
part à paris et elle découvre qu'il est
homosexuel et pour se faire admettre
elle se fait passer pour un garçon alors
au départ le film devait s'appeler maman
j'ai sucé papa non non c'est pas vrai
c'était une boutade
ah merde c'est pour ça des obligés de
main morte démenti à chaque fois passer
à la télé non c'est une blague
c'est une blague maman donc ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que le jeune fille en
question
s'habiller en garçon voilà un garçon ça
vous plaît cette chanson oui j'aime
sylvie vous chantiez ça commence
ethiopian au zinc
non pas ça quand tu vois je chantais des
chansons de bourvil surtout rassurez
vous je vais pas vous donner une chance
aux gros fait sa villa il va me demander
je connais marc bisson il va me demander
une chanson de boris becker vous auriez
pu j'en ai eu
thierry baril le couple claude rich
dieudonné et des fantasmes et oui oui
j'ai quand je les ai vus ensemble
j'étais sûr que c'était tu es bien pour
vous de votre fils
enfin quelqu'un qui prétend être votre
fils pour toi tu baises une fois avec
une bourde qui est attrapé le dos une
fois ou deux je ne sais plus moi elle
est grande à l'écart et j'ai pas dit
t'es gros ça non ça peut très bien
marcher
non tu me couper les cheveux mais c'est
la perruque que je vais couper banane
combien de temps il va falloir se la
coltiner la [ __ ] la jetée employés
français c'est quand même mon fils m'a
dit c'est même pas ces goûters tarbes où
on se parle mais non c'est pas moi
je suis sûr que tu te prends pour
françois mitterrand mais lui au moins il
a reconnu mazarine quand je pense que
moi pour moins que ça tu m'a pas parlé
pendant une semaine
mais pourquoi tu te compare à lui ça n'a
rien à voir est ce que tu veux que je me
planque ça ne va pas on ne sera pas dans
la cage aux folles des questions bonne
foi par d'appuyer je vais aller lui
offrir et nous allons leur chauffeur
twitter
le derrière de valérie lemercier en
cassette et en dvd
il y avait crevé comme dans tous les dvd
y avait beaucoup de choses en plus avant
mais oui bien sûr il ya il ya des tas de
dessins des photos un bêtisier une
chanson enfin il ya des bonus
alors voilà il ya plein de choses en
plus scalbert dans votre film c'est
qu'en fait la vraie marginal ce qu'est
ce qui est drôle c'est que la vraie
marginal cl quoi ces personnages mais
c'est elle qui n'a pas sa place c'est
aussi un film sur les gens qui savent
pas où aller ou savent pas quelle est
leur place
c'est ce groupe d'homosexuels ils sont
complètement dans l'establishment dans
la normalité et c'est elle qui débarque
de sa campagne qui en fait est l'intrus
oui ça c'est drôle
ouais c'est sympa vos parents et voulait
un garçon non quand et maintenant ils
voulaient ils ont eu quatre filles
bon allez pas les pauvres parce que
c'est bien quand même bon la campagne
quand même on préfère les garçons
non ça va ça va mais tous n'ont parfois
qu'attendait avoir un garçon et donc
quand vous êtes arrivé c'était une fille
ben oui bravo le crois je crois dans
l'émission vous appeler mon petit va
louvoyer oui vous parlez au masculin
quoi oui oui de très longtemps mais ça a
changé maintenant ma petit pour cent qui
est un petit effort ça y est ils
auraient appris
donc vous avez fait ce film pour vous
montrez à vos parents que si vous aviez
tu es un garçon serait pas été réparée
c'est pour ça que vos parents c'était
des agriculteurs mais chic quand même
non oui si vous voulez vous étiez quand
même les filles du patron il fallait
fallait pas la ramener parce que j'étais
défi du patron et beaucoup de gens du
village qui travaillait pour vos parents
d'où votre obsession ne pas déranger
d'ailleurs fallait quand même pas trop
la ramener fallait faire profil bas quoi
et alors à 9 ans mais c'est ça rigolait
pas je vais lemercier parce qu'elles ne
vont vous avez écrit un papier à votre
mère comme quoi vous vous maquillez
jamais la couche de fond de teint que
j'ai sur le visage c'est
là c'est impressionnant ses coups de
téléphone demain matin c'est à dire que
je pensais que c'était mal le maquillage
et j'aimerais que le pape
bennis dépôt de fonds de teint que ça me
ferait plaisir
après je me sentirai mieux dont vous
avez fait vous avez vous êtes fait
profil bas très longtemps et puis un
jour vous avez un petit peu baissé mais
en fait j'ai besoin de m'exprimer voyez
vous oui donc il a fallu que je
m'exprime j'ai commencé avant de faire
les visiteurs j'ai commencé par jouer un
spectacle 400 fois et puis j'ai fait
d'autres films aussi avant et voilà
c'est sûr que c'est un gros succès donc
malgré le succès que vous avez vous êtes
toujours un peu à côté j'ai toujours un
peu différente non bah je sais pas je
différentes de qui vous sentez pas
intégré me sentais toujours un peu
marginale non si c'est pas grave moi par
exemple sur l'histoire de féministes à
quand il fait des histoires de mannequin
dans les vitrines même parce que il ya
des choses les qualifiés aux mouvements
de libération des faits par exemple au
nom oui c'est une amie qui qui a fait ce
mouvement je trouve ça joli et ça me
voilà ça me ça me dérange pas je
l'envoie défiant en maillot de bain dans
les vitrines je serais plutôt bonnes en
plus il ya des fixes ça vous dérange
vous mais moi je m'en fous un peu
franchement non mais c'est que ça fait
un scandale ça vous savez ya toujours
des gens qui trouvent qu'il faut des
scandales pour tous alors j'ai des
choses quand même plus importante dans
la vie de savoir je pense que si une
fille elle peut gagner sa croûte en
étant là si ça lui va si ça va si elle
fait passer à 25 ans tant mieux pour eux
après c'est javier sanso si elle est en
face des peines dans la vie des gens qui
ont plus de 50 ans va passer rue bayard
parce que stéphane duhamel n'est pas
chaud chômage est un peu gênant les
filles dans les maillots de bain des
grands magasins ah bon d'abord il n'ya
pas le prit ensuite le sont pas
non mais parce qu'il est un peu marginal
c'est pas du tout au contraire moi c'est
moi je trouve ça bien simplement vous
êtes vous aimez bien être seul mais pas
trop sortir de chez vous vous aimez
partir en week-end pas les vacances pour
moi les vacances et être chez moi et mon
rêve le rêve de ma vie c'est de dormir
tous les soirs dans mon lit ouais je
n'aime pas aller dormir chez des gens et
comme donna pyjama une brosse à dents
des gens que je connais pas je sais pour
moi un cauchemar et personne t'oblige si
bien des fois on se retrouva en vacances
les gens enfin bon pour moi les vacances
et 7 chez moi je n'aime pas le soleil
parce que je d'abord je ne pense pas
cette norme en bon habitué des week-ends
ça ne m'intéresse pas bon enfin voila
mais j'ai plein d'autres centres
d'intérêts voilà et puis les spectacles
et puis écrire et puis enfin tout ça
quoi dites moi vous savez vous êtes la
cliente idéale pour lentilles portrait
chinois vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parfait alors donc vous connaissez le
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
fleur je serai un myosotis ça c'est
l'anti sport très chic une rose c'est
pas ça du tout justement si vous étiez
un défaut je serais très très sympa et
un petit peu chiant c'est une injure va
te faire cuire un oeuf pourri et mange
le nouvel avis la pestouille à un
accident je serai deux autos
tamponneuses qui se rentrent dedans une
perversion écoutez ce qui ne me regarde
pas une guerre je serai la guerre des
strings parce que je voudrais ouvrir une
guerre je suis contre les strings abord
vous épauler tang a offert des tangas
non je vais faire les bons grosse leipp
je n'explique pas ce que j'ai mené une
croisade ya cinq ans contre les caleçons
vous savez c'était ces gens de collants
avec le pied coupé et de femmes qui les
portait donc j'étais à devenu un peu la
chef anti qu'elles sont enfin bon
maintenant c'est les strings qu'on voit
de plus en plus avec les beaux jours et
je trouve ça un peu curieux parce que le
principe du string c'est quand même que
ça ne se voit pas or ça se voit vg sur
le contre vous
le tanga non plus non le tanga vous êtes
tanga string ou sli cool que son époux
bon ça n'aille pas le petit bateau le
string parce que j'en suis resté à une
définition que carlos a donné récemment
aux grosses têtes dit j'aime bien le
string parce que ça permet aux chats de
jouer avec un fils
oui avait un dessin de wismes un affreux
vous n'êtes pas vu c'était une femme sur
la plage couché sur le ventre et 20
hommes derrière elle avec la bid coupé
en deux dans le sens de la longueur et
elle lui elle se retourne à lui dit si
tu avais été un peu plus patiente
on continue une arme deux doigts coupe
faim parce qu'après la plus fins du tout
un supplice bad obliger tout le monde à
mettre des strings vous aussi vous aussi
moi j'ai pas de moi je porte pas de slip
ben voilà bo autant ne pas en mettre du
tout voilà moi j'ai ensuite j'ai rien
autant que je peux pas vous le dire jean
philippe le sait vous gagnez du temps je
m'habille toujours pareil je mets pas de
ce livre péché vite habillez vous étiez
un poison
je serai une poison vous êtes prêts si
vous étiez une [ __ ]
alors j'aime pas du tout ce mot parce
que je trouve ça un mot qu'on emploie
quand enfin les hommes emploi quand ils
sont un peu à cours d'idées alors qu'un
[ __ ] ont dix ados honey c'était mignon
un seul homme c'est que c'est un
compliment pour les hommes
ah bon ah oui ben je prends pas comme ça
oui on le pouvoir non vous philippe
sierra léonais ont scoré
je vais plus loin que vous c'est un
brevet de qualification
une salade
m
alors mon string par dessus tout ça sans
trophée bon si vous étiez un assassin
j'inviterais 21 oui ça normal
une torture torture je sais pas c'est
une torture vous seriez n'interdit de
terreur 10 ans est entraîneur on allume
[Applaudissements]
vous étiez une humiliation c'est une
infirmité à une infirmité j'ai une
infirmité sais que j'ai un bras plus
long que l'autre rien et ben c'est pas
drôle tous les jours au jour le jour
et quand même une grosse différence et
pour applaudir c'est pénible
regarde c'est pas possible le douloureux
peut pas applaudir non je peux pas voilà
j'ai un mois puis le code c'est toujours
le même d'ailleurs que ça y est le même
ça change par non non mais c'est vrai on
ben oui c'est vrai et pièces qui vous
gêne le plus celui qui est le plus long
jeu le plus court
je veux pas du tout moi je me bats pas
je compatis m gratter à deux niveaux
différents
je suis désolé mais cette fois voilà
c'est quoi
définira les remercier
j'avais deux faisaient d'amorçage très
bien mais là c'est franchement d'avancé
après la fois que je le dise que c'est
tout à fait une nouveauté donc voilà et
c'est assez sidérant cette histoire ben
ça s'est décidé il ya quelques semaines
mais voilà j'ai signé pour jouer c'est
le 15 septembre 26 septembre même si
c'est le cas c'est le cas c'est michel
même si c'est moi la bouilloire on a un
boulot à la rentrée saint martin mais
voilà mais bon je sais au fond
l'hébergeur wii et wii / gymnase mais a
très bien on joue trop loin
valérie lemercier
m
ça va pas mal
est ce que pour vous la fellation est
une chose naturelle dans le groupe je ne
sais pas ce que c'est c'est bien ce que
je disais c'est la nature telle attaque
bille en tête 10 ans et voilà alors vous
êtes déjà venu dans cette émission
nature raconter votre vie la drogue la
prostitution fille vit on va pas
recommencer à chaque fois je veux
simplement rappeler un petit peu votre
passé qui est brillant mais les
lemercier
vous avez grandi à gonfreville en
seine-maritime avec trois soeurs départ
en exploitant agricole à 18 ans vous
monter à paris vous fait le
conservatoire et les petits boulots
comme vendeuse aux galeries lafayette
nous a beaucoup aidés par la suite pour
caricaturer les gens vous débutez okano
zinc un bar homosexuel du marais et puis
vous commencez à faire des one man show
de la télévision du cinéma pour votre
premier one man show vous obtenez un
molière en télévision vous fait lady
palace dans la série 2 de jean michel
ribes au cinéma milou en mai avec louis
malle les visiteurs le numéro un vous
obtenez un césar du meilleur second rôle
vous refusez le second mais vous faites
un album avec bertrand burgalat et
ensuite vous commencez à réaliser des
films de pub et puis des films de cinéma
dont le génial le derrière qui
caricaturent la gauche caviar gay et là
vous obtenez pour troisième one man show
une récompense qui est encore un molière
voilà
beaucoup
c'est la seconde est en forme
bien où en sont vos rapports avec la
promotion à la télévision ça va je suis
là vous dites on ne pose jamais les
bonnes questions
non il ya des mauvais surtout peut-on
rire de tout oui ça fait du bien de rire
avec ce qui se passe en ce moment oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai que sa troisième
guerre mondiale j'ai vu un
alors donc vous êtes ici pour votre
troisième one man show celui qui a été
pendant six mois aux folies bergères et
qui maintenant part en tournée en
province avec un olympia l'olympia c'est
du 11 au 15 décembre et la tournée c'est
dans toute la france jusqu'en mars 2002
puis en tournée en ce moment ouais c'est
comment faire avec les mains je sais pas
6 novembre à clermont-ferrand dans le 63
le 8 à vichy sait dans quoi vichy je ne
sais pas le 9 à nevers dans le coin à 9
heures à 9 heures le 10 à bourges à
bourges devait être beau chez les
bourgeois et après en belgique en
belgique bien sûr à liège à bruxelles
voilà et on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
magnéto serge boudreau encore un tout
petit peu enflée
non mais ça tu lente et bien au pas
abonnés sur les rails
[Musique]
je m'appelle sont bien coûter j'ai 19
ans je suis élève dans une école de
tourisme gérard crinier je cherche un
stage d'enluminure
non mais ça m'arrive aussi de m'amuser
un mot si je sais ce que c'est avec
l'humour je pratique c'est pas moi qui
les ai pas peur et à droite beaucoup
c'est un gros challenge ce que tu sais
si c'est vrai que juliette c'est
juliette juliette de roméo et juliette
en fait elle aime pas romero non parce
que sa grande soeur de ma copine daphné
elle dit qu'en fait elle fait l'amour
avec le chanteur d'alibaba com
[Musique]
les états
comme un chat mort vous en foutez vous
avez pas besoin de faire de la promo
passerait bien je suis très contente
d'être parti en tournée très content
mais c'est tout ce qu il déteste
d'habitude on voit des êtres oui c'est
tout ce que j'étais simplement il ya un
tel décalage c'est à dire que on a
tellement pas d'image qui ont fini par
passer des trucs où je suis en train de
doubler tarzan ou comme ça que c'est
d'ailleurs de très mauvaise qualité ce
qu'on vient de voir c'est juste mon
petit caméscope qui a filmé un soir aux
folies bergères donc j'en ai assez des
petits vous mais c'est vrai qu'il n'ya
pas de cassettes il ya pas de spectacle
n'est pas filmé oui c'est ça ça vous
fait jamais de cassettes de vos
spectacles n'y aura pas de trace non il
y en a 2 aucun des trois camps vous
serez mort tu auras plus rien voilà il
n'y aura plus rien à ok c'était ça ouais
c'est la vie alors c'est un spectacle
est très au point des textes très
ciselée très très juste autour d'une
douzaine de personnages qui ont tous un
point commun c'est d'être des victimes
on peut dire non un peu oui un petit peu
un petit peu mal barré le personnage
typique lemercier la burj catho qui
ramassent des cormorans mazout et qui
appelle sa soeur bene ça c'est la belle
inouïe ouais bah bill ça c'est un
classique
oui c'est à dire que j'avais pas fait
dans le précédent de bourges comme ça
mais là je les reprises ça m'amusait de
la mettre dans un autre contexte de la m
en bretagne c'est surtout qu'elle a une
soeur qui est très dépressive et qu'elle
est très méchant dont il ya une vieille
défense est une jeune et fois ces jeunes
on l'a droguée où elle est assez j'avais
n'est allé s'est fait stériliser
on a pris 95 par ses parents mais bon
elle est mal barré aussi une paysanne
une prof de danse russe une étudiante
très méchante et puis des passages en
string comme on vient de le voir la
belle le belge de cinar lebel je veux
qu'ils racontent à son fils comment sa
mère était bonne ouais ouais nférieure
sa légende
c'est à dire que c'est très drôle
d'ailleurs parce que je suis en tournée
depuis un mois plus je suis dans le nord
plus ça parle aux gens c'est à dire
vraiment que j'ai des gens j'ai joué à
maubeuge l'autre jour c'est vrai que les
gens sont très près de la belgique dans
toutes les expressions belge et donc
j'ai hâte de le jouer à bruxelles en
belgique
vous n'êtes toujours pas mariés vous non
plus non c'est lors de la mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez les filles
et puis une mecque non c'est vrai
jusqu'à zélés bien il reste que des
barreaux d'une part les nous marquons
vous allez perdre et jamais vous marier
mais s'il aimerait bien mais je sais pas
fini on voulait lancer un appel à la
télé non pas du tout non surtout pas non
non non c'est sûr parce que vous savez
comment ça marche on conçoit des
nombreux jamais jamais non mais c'est
bon aussi j'ai reçu une lettre
aujourd'hui on me demandait des photos
avec des tapes tenues différentes
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre des tas de
tenues différentes et moi envoyer les
photos non non mais je fais pas
d'alliance maintenant on fait des non
plus non ça va ça va venir tout ça doit
venir tout seul j'accueille valérie
lemercier christopher thompson
cette partie nous faire applaudir la
avec le film qui sort tout et vous
faites ça vous plaît d'être applaudi
quand même mais beaucoup merci merci les
gars moi je vous dis ça parce que vous
avez déclaré l'idée de me fondre dans
l'anonymat me comble si cela s'arrête et
demain ça me serait égal me montrer
n'est pas un truc facile pour moi c'est
vrai aussi mais c'est son vrai de
sombrer mais c'est à la fois une joie et
une souffrance ça va ça va bien ça va
d'autant mieux que après palais royal
qui a été un carton absolu c'est quand
même un film qui a fini à 3 millions
d'entrées à peu près un an presque
presque on va en reparler tout à l'heure
vous êtes ici avec christopher thompson
combien ça va
chacun peut lire ils sont ensemble c'est
la première télé on semble donc voilà
le temps semble vous êtes ici pour un
film excellent que je recommande
chaleureusement à tous mes amis que les
spectateurs qui s'appelle fauteuils
d'orchestre voilà c'est un film de
danièle thompson sur un scénario de
danièle thompson et de vous christopher
thompson avec cécile de france valérie
lemercier albert dupontel claude
brasseur dany et vous christopher
thompson alors c'est une comédie chorale
ce qui veut dire qu'on suit plusieurs
personnages mais là il ya une unité de
lieu c'est le bas de l'avenue montaigne
autour du théâtre des champs elysées du
bar des théâtres et du plaza athénée
alors c'est un quartier donc avec sa vie
de quartier qui offre beaucoup de
possibilités romanesque unité de lieu
donc mais aussi unité de temps ça se
passe en trois jours on suit des gens
vous citer une phrase de capra qui
disent qui intéresse les gens
ce sont les gens c'est vrai c'est vrai
je crois c'est l'oeuvre de la matière
première
alors on suit plusieurs personnages
cécile de france qui est engagée comme
serveuse au bar des théâtres et qui va
croiser les trois protagonistes
d'événements artistiques ayant lieu le
même jour dans le même immeuble
alors il ya dupontel qui est un pianiste
virtuose qui prépare un concert au
théâtre des champs elysées valérie qui
est une actrice très populaire une star
de la télé qui répètent une pièce de
feydeau pour la comédie des champs
elysées
claude brasseur qui est un grand
collectionneur d'art qui vend tout aux
enchères à la salle drouot montaigne
évidemment tous ces personnages que
rencontrent ces s'ils sont en crise
c'est des personnages qui ont qui ont
qui on voulait qu'ils ont vraiment tout
dans la vie qui sont absolument comblé
et qui veulent autre chose alors le
pianiste qui est booké pendant les six
ans à venir et veut absolument autre
chose jouer pour pour les gens qui ne
connaissent pas la musique lascive jouer
dans les prisons dans les objets et aux
exo 1000 vosges où il veut à yves jouer
de la musique lascive pour pour des gens
qui ne sont pas forcément des
lymphocytes aficionado des hystériques
aider les gens qui qui qui qui ont accès
à ça il veut autre chose
valérie vous êtes une star je rêve de
tourner avec des grands réalisateurs et
le collectionneur brasseur qui a tout
donné à sa passion lui voit plus de sens
à tout ça il
le temps crise lui aussi à lui est un
c'est quelqu'un qui a amassé
une collection d'aliments ce magnifique
toute sa vie c'était sa raison de vivre
avec avec sa femme qui qui se trouve
être la mère du personnage de
l'interprète et on découvre qu'ils ont
basé leur vie là dessus sur cette
collection il a dix ans donné ils
agissent comme de castor qui qu'un qui
ont pour lutter contre l'usure du temps
ils ont basé leur avis là dessus et au
moment où il vend sa collection son fils
était un personnage a priori pas très
pas très gai un peu terne
en tout cas terre dans sa présence à lui
vient lui demander des comptes
alors c'est un film intelligent cultivé
très qualité france à une époque où on
brûle les ambassades pour des
caricatures on voit ce qu'on pourrait
perdre quand on voit ce film
merci on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
j'ai regardé tous les deux votre caméra
vous à dire magnéto serge alors laquelle
c'est le cas le rouge on y est tous en
train de temps à pezens 1-2-3 maniel
tous âges et des catégories de personnes
ceux qui se disent quand le téléphone
sonne ce qui encore puis ceux comme moi
qui se disent tu sais peut bien
bastien avoue j'ai toujours des
vestiaires j'ai toujours été vendeuse à
j'ai toujours été serveuse j'ai
travaillé dans les brasseries à mâcon
c'est pas une brasserie ici et qui sait
pas mâcon c'est un microcosme hissant à
jour vous avais plus envie tout serveuse
tout le monde comprendra mais vous êtes
pianiste personnes dont j'aurais voulu
être une artiste comme dit la chanson
mais personne n'a jamais ce qui veut
jessica vous en tout cas vous avez tout
ce que les gens voient tout de même pas
je me trimballe et pendant toute la
pièce avec cette famille de gallinacés
sur la tête
de plus je merde [ __ ] ils me regardent
bah non il regarde
ma femme on trouve des shows mon
quartier c'est vrai qu'à 100 400 milles
sur le balcon à 400 milles qu'ils mieux
400 mais tu croit vivre une grande
histoire d'amour et moi je te dis que tu
vas te faire plumer par une [ __ ]
aujourd'hui je fais quoi commerce
j'ai envie d'arrêter ce feuilleton de
merde afin d'agrandir aimant vous adore
peux plus je n'en dise quoi
des neiges d'être amoureux je reviens te
chercher
la nazairienne celui qui quelqu'un je
savais que tu
je savais que l'on à travers ce concert
le frelon
je reviens te chercher
bonne place car voilà près d'orthez de
données
nous sommes sortis le 15 mai
un régal alors la dérive
votre personnage est pris dans un
véritable tourbillon quoi elle veut tout
faire très vite elle tourne la nuit elle
répète le jour voilà et c'est l'essai
d'accumuler les rôles et c'est surtout
elle essaie d'en avoir un autre avec
avec un grand réalisateur qui est joué
par un autre grand réalisateur ski et
ciné polar
elle rêve de jouer simone de beauvoir et
malheureusement elle est too much tivi
comme on dit voilà je pense que c'est
comme véronique jeunesse qui voudraient
tourner avec desplechin elle aimerait
bien voilà autre chose c'est vrai qu'en
france mais très vite catalogué
retrouver la télé on ne peut faire que
de la télé quand on est aussi certaines
actrices parfois on n'en veut pas et
certaines tout à coup on en veut pour
tous les rôles c'est à dire que tout à
coup l'une pour enfin voilà une actrice
à la mode pourrait on pourrait le
proposer
edith piaf ensuite marie antoinette
ensuite enfin bon une jeune ouvrière une
bourgeoise femmes on s'est tout à coup
elle n'a pas la carte en tout cas parce
que c'est une actrice de télé donc c'est
mal vu
je suis pas très mal voire très mal
qu'on la reconnaisse enfin c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'elle est cette s'est levé
un peu de vouloir séduire le réalisateur
ya toujours un fan qui passe et qu'on
leur connaît qui demande la suite de
l'épisode et qui voit les étant rattrapé
par rapport à la télévision par sa
notoriété par son feuilleton en même
temps c'est grâce à ça qu'il l'a choisi
puisqu'il voit une cassette du
feuilleton que son sérieux a donné oui
voit ça à la télé en fait arrivé dans
son hôtel il la voit à la télé
finalement complètement surréel il
flashe sur elle il ya une scène
d'anthologie serbe chiché votre dîner à
sydney pollack c'est énorme mais c'était
très agréable de jouer avec lui un
énorme ballon c'est énorme
il ya un moment où vous vouliez - votre
film je suis prêt à le faire pour rien
et il vous dit il faut jamais rien faire
pour rien ouais ouais
alors allez un peu bouffé par son métier
elle râle les chiante les culotté mais
elle est touchante quand même on aime
bien quoi finalement l'aiment bien parce
que parce qu'elle en veut quel est son
rôle pour une fois moi qui suis parfois
un peu noir se termine bien se termine
très bien pour elle parce qu'il obtient
ce rôle et et
et elle s'est débrouillée toute seule
pour pour ressembler alors qu'elle joue
du feydeau pour ressembler à simone de
beauvoir en enlevant son chapeau et
voilà il est c'est un personnage est
plutôt positif alors vous dites à
travers ce personnage et travers
catherine danièle thompson veut dire que
rien n'est grave c'est vrai c'est ce que
j'aime chez elle et c'est que n'est pas
dépressive c'est que c'est un metteur en
scène est légal et le tournage et
familiale c'est agréable
voilà je crois qu elle l aime beaucoup
la vie et ça sent dans son film c'est
vrai vous dites à travers ses films elle
aime à rendre la ville légère hausse il
dit ça mais oui c'est très juste c'est
pour ça que je vous cite vous galérez
non mais c'est vrai quand on sort de ce
film on est on est bien on est content
on voit des mois ça m'a beaucoup ému
personnellement il paraît ou dominique
segall voulez oui il me l'a dit est ce
que vit normalement il vient bah oui
dominique
m
voilà
[Musique]
c'est toi comment ça va alors est-ce
qu'on a bien parlé du film est bien
parce que j'étais fier d'autant plus que
j'étais à la sortie de la projection je
t'ai vu très émus très émus l'a touchée
par ce film moi ce que j'aime au cinéma
c'est pleurer ici
et donc c'est vrai que j'avais pleuré
pour joyeux noël pour le film de
mergault que magnifique avec michel
blanc est là mais qu'est ce qui vous a
fait pleurer en fait exact sais pas je
me suis rendu compte finalement de tout
ce qu'on pouvait perdre de cette
légèreté de cette culture de cette
intelligente c'est pas ça m'a ça m'a
touché c'est peut-être l'époque aussi
qui qui fait ce à quoi tout ce qui se
passe dans le monde en ce moment je me
suis dit c'est nous ça c'est notre
culture quoi merci à bientôt
dominique chez les mecs qui passent le
plus dans tout le monde en parle
évidemment c'est non - dominique ce gars
voilà exactement
j'ai tout compris alors la vie et
légères pour vous aussi
valérie donc on disait que palais royal
était presque à 3 millions d'entrées si
votre troisième film comme scénariste
réalisatrice et actrice
et vous êtes nominé pour le césar de la
nommer thierry ah bon moi j'ai rien aux
mines amont non parce que nominé c'est
les élèves de la star ac
je vais dire nommé alors donc vous êtes
nommé pour le césar de la meilleure
actrice catherine deneuve pour le césar
du meilleur second rôle féminin
hu est aussi d'avis dans le même film
dans le même film non c'est pas mal de
contente super content alors au départ
le film se passait pas du tout dans un
canton écrivait le scénario ça se
passait dans cette es l'histoire de la
femme d'un homme d'état c'est à dire une
femme qui n'a pas choisi ses places et
qui ajuste épouser un homme et que voilà
et qui se retrouve moi ça m'amuse
toujours de voir des gens qui seront
obligés d'être dans des endroits où ils
ne sont pas très con inde est forcément
donc elle a épousé un homme et il faut
qu'elle se tape tout le boulot de
princesse qui est pas toujours marrant
et puis ensuite on vous est donné au
scénario une dimension un peu point de
vue images du monde en vous inspirant
des cours scandinave du benelux de
monaco cost espèce de la royauté
pacotille oui absolument
alors vous dites c'est un film
républicain car je ne suis pas très
royaliste
non je suis pas très royaliste j'ai
l'impression que les quand on est quand
on est oui n oui on n'a pas forcément
les épaules pour pour succéder à son
père mais dans le film c'est vrai que le
prince arnaud qui jouait par lambert
wilson s'est pas vraiment enfin voilà
c'est pas forcément une flèche donc
c'est très marrant de voir des gens qui
sont tout à coup voilà amené à renier il
combat voilà vous en connaissez des rois
n'ont aucun bon on appelait en voici
henri d'orléans
[Musique]
bonsoir mon seigneur voici le premier
prince que je touchais jaffe palais
royal c'est vachement bien quand même
alors si la france était une monarchie
vous seriez roi c'est pour ça que je
tenais à ce que vous rencontriez valérie
lemercier
alors vous êtes royalistes vous pas
comme pas comme valérie non pas parce
que valérie a déclaré que ce qu'elle
aimait pas finalement dans le système
monarchique c'était le côté caste
supérieure le dis que c'est un paradoxe
insupportable mais elle a tout à fait
raison à la merci henri iv c'est bien
orléans
monseigneur l'ouest et là je termine ma
dame et on parle et on parle de votre
bouquin juste après donc merci j'avais
pu terminer si vous le voulez bien
donc vous avez été nommé non pas nominé
comme mondial a joué la meilleure
actrice pour les césars mais en plus
vous présenter la soirée
oui je suis et 13 de ses rêveries
maîtresse de cérémonie m6 valérie voilà
est votre mission c'est de faire oublier
gad elmaleh qui a été excellent à ça pas
de faire oublier ses deux lui succède et
la barre est haute
ouais je cherche pas à le faire oui moi
je vais regarder ce soir là je suis sur
cette formidable n'en suis pas du tout
inquiet si si bah oui je suis un peu
mais non j'avais un pouvoir comique vous
avez fanny bones comme on dit vous êtes
drôle donc c'est sûr ça va être bien
quoique vous fassiez les gens vont se
marrer valérie savait bien
vous préparez un peu non évidemment oh
là là on va continuer la préparation on
va faire une interview au coaching césar
est-ce que vous porterez comme tenue
très jolie robe noire portée ou en
anorak sur vos interviews avant est ce
que vous allez dire que vous espérez la
boire mais qu'avant tout c'est un grand
honneur d'être nommé
j'espère surtout qu'on vend des
interviews mais avant on a à ce moment
là je pourrai répondre d'accord dirait
qu'ils avaient accepté de présenter
parce que vouliez pas rester assise
pendant trois heures c'est vrai j'aime
bien être debout en général d'ailleurs
je peux 7 me mettre debout pour être on
apprenait apprenent est debout et frais
comme en outre il fait comment pour le
standing ovation vous vous levez les
innovations c'est à dire je serai pas
dans la salle thierry je sais je serai
sur scène j'ai de beaux donc je serais
déjà de bouche comme un gout toute la
soirée puisque dans la salle au moment
où elle va pas forcément ice est prévu
comme ça ben je sais pas olala salaires
organisée c'est très clair alors
imaginons danser l'ère des nominations
meilleure actrice
on dit les nominations meilleure actrice
donc pendant que les deux crétins qui
vont nous remplacer sur scène par lequel
peut-être vous faites c'est très
important de ces l'écran est coupée en
quatre et là on voit si vous êtes
seraient les deux crétins sur scène à
vous faites tout mais oui donc c'est
votre année on ne voit pas pendant trois
ans mais alors après dit non
quelle tête vous ferez non vous souriez
pendant ce moment là oui c'est de voir à
huy bien
et le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à valérie lemercier
[Musique]
oui
c'est normal
si sa constante
quand vous avez sur scène vous dit
pardon pardon comme ça comme ils font
tous savaient pardon pardon pas pourquoi
mais je serai sur scène
pardon avait d'ailleurs fait semblant de
tomber de façon à ce que vous soyez dans
les bêtisiers dans les 20 prochaines
années oui oui vous faites nous des
trucs pour les bêtisiers parce qu'il ya
des gens à la télé qui vivent de ça mais
on croit ferme un bêtisier avant même
vous pleurez à ce moment là si vous
l'avez écouté et j'ai pas pleurer depuis
l'âge de 18 ans n'ont donc vous avez
pleuré pour l'or souvent donc c'est
normal
donc je vais pas commencer samedi
prochain vous pleurez monseigneur vaut
ça m'arrive à envoyer au signalement au
cinéma aussi
toi tu pleures venir et non ça m'est
arrivé ces derniers temps bah oui oui
avec célia une fan de guillaume célia
pour mercier qui en premier vous direz
c'est avant tout le travail d'une équipe
une rencontre avec un réalisateur
oui sûrement vu que c'est vous le
réalisateur non mais je remercierai
c'est vrai que j'ai eu à faire un très
très grand réalisateur et j'ai une femme
formidable homme formidable
vous avez remercié la grande famille du
cinéma français veulent vraiment faut il
penser à ça 1 vous féliciterez les trois
filles qui ont perdu quand même bien sûr
surtout qu'elles sont pas mal non plus
les autres
ah bon
vous oubliez votre césar sur scène
histoire de faire rire un peu non non
non ah les intermittents du spectacle
vous y penserez oui oui un petit mot oui
je dirais mme thibout vous mettrez un
bonnet péruvien c'est vers là non
et si vous perdez alors qu'elle tentait
de voir la tête que vous allez faire un
malheur et si vous perdez
ohlala
ouais ça va être bien non parce que je
veux pas la voir
je m'entraîne à plein pourquoi vous
n'avez pas à domicile parce que tous les
gens qui présentent les césar n'ont
jamais son quand ils sont nommés et non
pas de militant c'est à dire le gad
elmaleh antoine de caunes
edouard baer voilà ne longe date estimée
bien sûr c'est que l'horreur mais si oui
c'est comme ça annulée mais non je
préfère les présentes
bon alors allez c'est bon livre on
atteint là nous remettre votre césar est
ce que vous appelez yvan à table avant
de l'embrasser
non je dis d'aller les opticiens
si le casse
de thouars girl
si tu me posais la question est ce que
ce sont toutes les mêmes biens non
vraiment pas non car ce suicide
oh non quoi quoi quoi quoi vous devez
dire du mal de votre film palais ouais
je peux en dire oui c'est l'abattement
c'est un très mauvais film avec des très
mauvais dialogue est très mauvais
comédiens deneuve est épouvantable
lambert wilson épouvantable michel
aumont j'en parle même pas enfin dans
c'est une catastrophe personnelle et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu